my guest is enough Tali Bennett he's
Education Minister
he's also leader of the right-wing
Jewish home party his prescription for
ending the crisis to remove once and for
all any hope of the Palestinians for an
independent sovereign state what makes
him think that they or the outside world
would ever accept that
enough timely Bennett welcome to
confidence oh thank you it's great being
here
you gave an interview last year you were
asked about the freeze in the peace
process
freeze that you supported you said the
process was suicide we saved the country
okay the violence today it doesn't look
as though you saved the country at all
does it well Tim you know for the past
100 years we've had roughly 40 rounds of
violence with radical Islam in 1921 1929
1936-1939 a point it's not getting
better this is nothing new and until the
Muslim world accepts Israel's right to
exist and we were here way before the
Islam even started it will go on but you
know what amid all this turbulence
Israel is growing Israel is thriving as
are its people so I'm very optimistic US
Secretary of State says if you want to
know what a one state solution looks
like take a look at what's happening at
the moment anyone who thinks otherwise
can measure what unitary looks like by
just looking at what's been occurring in
Israel over the last few weeks he says
the two-state solution
there's no alternative quite the
contrary what we're seeing as a result
of the Oslo Accords that injected
terrorists okay well nothing I mean you
know I'm talking about the point the
point is that when we went a hundred
percent all the way in 1999 in the Camp
David Accords the old Barak was willing
to divide Jerusalem willing to form a
full-fledged Palestinian state you know
what happened they murdered a thousand
Israelis as a result Tel Aviv Jerusalem
Haifa we had buses blowing up everywhere
so the murders go on on both sides this
this approach known the notice go on IV
mentally disagree you wrote it you wrote
about it in August women you was
somewhat about Jewish extremist
numbering an 18 month old baby and you
know what the big difference is when a
ver you know everyone has extremists the
difference is what is the difference Tim
is that when there's an extremist on our
side the whole leadership of Israel goes
out of its way to
fight that wears on the Palestinian side
when they murder Jews you know what
Mahmoud Abbas does he pays the money he
funds you families you say this is
mastitis no no he gives prizes to
murderers and while we put them in jail
and that's the precise difference well
do you you you blame the violence on
Palestinian incitement
you said Abbas is the head of the snake
of incitement I think that's that that
is correct but you too are blamed in for
intentionally provoking and inciting
violence specifically by the defense
minister in the cabinet in which you
serve IDF army reported the radio
reported October 7th Moshe Ya'alon told
the cabinet ministers from the Jewish
home party your party are provoking the
field and causing an increase in the
number of settler attacks both on
Palestinians and soldiers yeah that's
nonsense
what work so he doesn't know what he's
talking about either Defense Minister
Tim said the big picture is the big
picture is that were in our Jewish home
here okay it's been our Jewish home for
about 3,800 years we had a Jewish state
here in three thousand years ago we had
a Jewish state that was destroyed by
Romans in 70 AD we were expelled by the
Spaniards from Spain a thousand years
ago he told us we were expelled from
England roughly a thousand years ago we
have the Germans who butchered us and
now were at home I'll tell you how the
organization and unlike unlike where you
lived IRA made you live in London and I
know that it's a it's a walk in the park
compared to being in the toughest region
in the world and we're surrounded
address that I will address I'm
addressing precisely the point what
we're doing here is building the only
democracy that respects full equal
rights of the Arab minority of the Jews
of everyone in the midst of the most
turbulent difficult place water come to
and you're coming in and attacking that
that's precisely the common media
approach of attacking we're on the right
side
we're on the right I'm telling you what
defeat me because it is saying okay you
know you miss voted I I don't know what
you miss old I say that the Army's hands
are tied and that the armies and I'm
happy to report foreign wave of terror
this fuels the people who choose to take
matters into their eye I'm he's accusing
you of doing I'm very happy
that the Army's hands are no longer tied
because of what I pushed for we will
defend ourselves
don't the symmetry where there is no
symmetry the current they are attacking
us we're defending our errant volume
will continuously the current violence
has centered around the long-standing
procedures relating to the holy sites in
Jerusalem specifically the Temple Mount
that Haram al-sharif the Prime Minister
has been at pains to tell the
Palestinians of the rest of the world
that the status quo is not going to be
changed the status quo whereby Jews do
not pray at the Temple Mount but some
leading right-wingers have been
undermining the Prime Minister haven't
think you will Justice Minister I let's
check it said a year ago that Jews have
the right to pray at the Temple Mount
your MP you know Maga weighed in said he
wants a new temple built there
this is undermining the idea that the
status quo is not going to be changed is
that you want to change the status quo
don't you Tim the only place in the
Middle East that exercises full
religious rights for all religions
Christian Christianity and Muslims and
Jews is Israel so no one should tell us
how to govern Temple Mount Temple Mount
is open for Muslims to pray and they
roughly two and a half Muslims have
prayed at Temple Mount in the past year
while only about 12,000 Jews that's just
let's put things about portioned it's
also and we are we is a large amount of
rabbinical advice on this and views that
says Jews should not actually pray on
the Temple Mount
Wow you know now you're representing the
rabbis you know that's a whole new
that's a whole new no no this this is
the status quo isn't it that Jews do not
by a large pray at the time I don't
dispute the status quo it will go on and
I'm very happy that now a British
journalists are quoting rabbis in order
to promote Jewish illogical rules
so when reality the reality tempt him
now back to reality yeah we have a very
sensitive thing called Temple Mount the
holiest place on earth produce the third
holiest place on earth for Muslims will
continue to run this in a very
responsible way
unlike the Palestinians
by the way burnt Joseph tomb just two
weeks ago because that's what happens
when you you know culture you and so all
not to check your not tonight oh I said
I just because I'm twenty change
Mustaine's Tim oak optics in there in
Egypt are murdered Christians and the
Palestinian Authority are murdered their
way with and only play know that the
topic is who takes care of religious
freedom and the only country in the
Middle East Tim that takes care of full
religious freedom is Israel let's look
at reality yes it is it's something this
was in citement because you accused
Mahmoud Abbas of inside that there is a
yes because I was about history of
incitement not right right you're right
all right yes countries you mentioned
you mentioned Mahmoud Abbas look Mahmoud
Abbas pays a monthly salary to the fifth
every murder you said this much Abbas
has parades arraigned the Shahid's those
who you saw this senator are saying to
you there's over yes history of
incitement from the right wing here in
Israel isn't there the Prime Minister
himself hasn't shied away from it he was
forced to apologize after tweeting on
election day that the Arabs are coming
out in droves to vote the rule of the
right is in danger the Arab voters are
moving in drove the message clearly
inciting anti-arab sentiment quite right
you know I'm Minister of Education of
twitten be tolerated in any other 2.2
million kids including Arab kids
including Druze kids and I take care of
each and every child as if it's my own I
don't care what race they are or what
religion Israel with all its
imperfections is certainly the most
democratic the most tolerant country in
the region you want to compare to
Lebanon or to Syria perhaps where
they're cutting heads off or perhaps
this Saudi Arabia or perhaps to Egypt
shall see where the tolerance is I think
you're the Minister for here you know
Minister facin and that's why it's a
Lebanon that's why precisely Tim why I
am promoting and is tolerant why did I
call the rally in sight whenever it from
the right whenever there's incitement
I don't accept any incitement whether
it's from the right whether it's from
the left
so did you can buy Eli been dyin I
condemn
I condemn phalanxes I'm all incitement
of anyone from any side but dig in the
souls of old Jews are higher than those
of Christians Muslims or anyone else did
you condemn him for that
I can this is a serving minute all no
he's not a minister you should do your
homework but I condemn all is there any
defense right I condemn all sort of
incitement but the difference is that
over the past two months dozens of
Muslim radicals have come out to murder
Jews and I Mouse and Jews are not
murdering here I'm talking and talking
to the arabs about what then I will get
to you and then to do so about with you
my backyard
I fight incitement and I will always
fight incitement whether it's against so
did you come out here then I'll I been
the high condensing report of incitement
very clearly so how is that he was still
allowed to serve in the government I you
know after saying something like that in
a government world worse of every and we
do serve everyone you know what every
Arab incandescence my sins as interfere
and I'll tell you this I'll tell you
every Arab in the Muslim world would
pray to be in my education system in
Israel's education system because they
get here full equal rights in fact they
get more investment for a child than in
the Jewish sense your president and and
that's why I'm so proud of this is that
and and while you know what you're doing
you're taking very narrow examples this
is very common in the European media and
you're doing a good job at that and
twist into reality no I'm not a reality
putting it is you know your your child
in reality you would assign that's your
job to challenge what you know it
reminds me of the the latest BBC where
an Arab had been I've dodged oh and the
Arab was killed so the obviously the
title was an Arab killed and no one says
that he tried to murder Tommy Benton so
let's talk about led has it a larger
issue and this is something that your
president has drawn attention to he says
Israel is sick with racism these are his
words he said last year he's also
horrified by the thuggish myth that's
permeated the national dialogue why
don't you speak out about that
I will you know we have one and a half
million Arabs living in Israel they
exercise full equal rights they have
enjoy all the privileges that every Jew
they vote the president says this about
discrimination do you want to hear or do
you want to talk the every Jew and every
Arab votes for the Knesset we have a
dozen Arab members of Knesset I can't
recall Christians members of parliament
in fact I don't recall any free
Parliament in the radical Muslim world
so we're here a beautiful example of a
light house in a storm we've got and go
through the air with races nobody not
aggressive no if I dispute that I
disagree and even says there's severe
discrimination against the Arab
community which is inconsistent with the
Democratic nature of the state which you
keep trumpeting and that's why as
Minister of Economy that's why as
Minister of Economy I open dozens of
employment centers for Arab women
that's why I've Minister of Education
I'm providing the Arabs with Hebrew from
kindergarten and not third grade so
they'll be able to get a good job that's
why I'm allowing Israelis to learn
Arabic that's why I learned Arabic for
heaven's sake because we are going to
live here together and that's not the
same no one's going anywhere we have to
realize that no one's going anywhere the
Jews are here to stay the Arabs are here
to stay
we have to live together because we have
many things that Minister the same
economy ministry that you used to head
reported that complaints of anti-arab
discrimination increased by more than
120 percent in the first half of this
year I think many Jews doesn't support
which it totally supports it we're in
the midst of a wave of Muslim Arab
terror and I can understand even if I
don't accept I can understand the fear
of a Jew who's afraid that the person
next to him will murder him that's why
we have to fight intolerance but first
of and foremost we have to bring back
security the discrimination that
President Rivlin talked about goes back
many years doesn't it because if you
take the or Commission report on the
causes of the Second Intifada which was
led by Judge Theodore or specifically
the events of October 2000 he talked
about the government handling of the
Arab sectors primarily neglectful
Scrivener tree he said the state did not
do enough or try hard enough to create
equality for its Arab citizens or to
uproot discriminatory or unjust
phenomena and we're fixing just that and
that's what according to the president
that slide talks about Sudan that's
quite all right and that's why as
Education Minister I've invested a
billion shekel in the Arab community
look I care about every child in Israel
whether he's Jewish
whether he's Arab we're in an imperfect
place we're not in la-la land we're in a
reality a very tough reality where we
want to create a beautiful Jewish
democracy in Israel while we're
surrounded by the craziest people in the
world it might be easier to live in
London and sit and give comments then
when you live here but we live in a
reality and and do you think you're
helped in doing that in creating the
kind of society you want by bulldozing
the houses of suspected terrorists not
suspected we're talking about bulldozing
the house of terrorists something that's
been strongly opposed in the past by the
international community I was given up
by the army so the army gave it up
themselves look here's the deal these
terrorists are willing to die now if
someone's coming and willing to kill you
and you know he doesn't care he's
willing to commit suicide then the only
way to prevent it is if he knows that
his house will be destroyed and and
therefore you create the the deterrence
necessary to prevent the next terror
attack we don't want to do this but when
when hundreds of Muslims radical Islamic
terrorists are out to kill me and my
family yes I will defend myself and you
know what I'm not going to apologize for
it I'm general error' chanee who wrote
the report in 2005 on the basis of which
the army stopped bulldozing houses he
said just the other day he said that
Palestinian resolve was actually
strengthened by the demolitions and that
the motivation of individual
Palestinians to fight against Israel was
probably increased by these demolitions
I I so it's a counterproductive policy
that's what he says I differ I think
that when a terrorist now the equation
for a terrorist is very positive he
knows this I go I kill a Jew or two I
die that's fine
I get to have 70 virgins in the next
world
my family will get a monthly salary I'll
be paraded as a hero we have to change
this equation that's the problem as long
as the equation is is so powerful
they're going to continue killing dozens
of Jews and at the same time at the same
time as you pulling down houses and
there are actually a lot of thousands of
demolitions that are pending by the
civilian administration the same time as
you want to do that you want the
Palestinians to recognize Israel as the
Jewish state is religious state when
when Israelis themselves can't agree on
what the Jewish state is the Juris that
is very simple it's my home what about
the disagreements in a way the
nation-state what about the nation-state
that you know you're talking you're
asking about it elicit disagree yes just
open up the the most popular book in the
world it's called the Bible and you can
find it why do they have to say I don't
know I don't need them to say anything I
don't need their I don't need anything
from them so why are they being I'm not
asking the Prime Minister I'm suggesting
- for my Minister I'm not suggesting to
form a Palestinian state in the midst of
Israel I think that would be a profound
mistake I V mentally opposed the notion
of forming another failed Arab state in
the heart of Israel that's crazy
well all the rest are falling apart and
disintegrating into tribal structures so
here we're going to try another
artificial one why do I want to commit
suicide I'll also remind you Tim hold on
I'll remind you we tried this in 2005 we
did the big experiment in Gaza we did
all three things the international
community wanted we pulled back to the
67 lines we pulled out all our soldiers
and you know what we expelled 8,000 Jews
from their Rome by force and what did we
get days after and you just don't enjoy
anything that moves into Gaza no no
that's it lately news from outside no
because what happened even David Harden
a few years ago coated the prison
Timothy said it was we it wait it was
gonna be the Singapore of the Middle
East it was open but then what are you
holding it no you gotta go you're wrong
the Singapore besides the fact that
you're stating wrong
everything's okay the reality is quite
the country when we gave them Gaza we
said go build a Singapore and you wanna
you know what they shot thousands of
missiles from there on to Israel which
is why yes we need to defend ourselves
what do you do when every centimeter of
land that you hand the radical Islamist
terms into a base of Iran and radical
Islam what do you do we did it in
Lebanon and now we have a hundred and
fifty thousand missiles there we did it
in against Samaria I think killed a
thousand yes I understand I'm talking
about what you do I'm talking what would
you do and what you're not prepared to
do is to end the occupation because you
don't think it is an occupation that's
correct you always say how are you
occupied London how can you occupy land
how can you occupy land when it's not
there already Europe Jews have been
living in Jerusalem way before British
people were living in what your own
haiku okay was it an occupation you know
my court actually calls it belligerent
occupation on an international basis
international law we're talking about
disputed territory former head of Shin
Bet Avraham Shalom since we've become a
brutal occupation force here's a man who
was charged with the security of the
State of Israel
Carmi Gillon another former head of Shin
Bet say we're making life intolerable
for millions of people directly
challenging the things that you're tell
that's correct about what you're doing
for Israel well if you and I go out on
the street now we can walk around you'll
meet Arabs who have good jobs who vote
for the Knesset the same Knesset I'm a
member and he says it these are former
heads of Shin Bet yeah you know I always
believe reality is stronger than any
words you know you know very well that
one and a half million Israeli Arabs
vote for the Knesset they pay taxes in
Israel they get all equal rights in
Israel and I'm they're very good
Education Minister trying to do my best
to make their kids get a better
education that's the reality there's no
place better on earth for Arabs than in
Israel that is the reality one of the
might be tough for you to accept that
but that is the reality me to accept or
not but one of the things that you said
last year was that the world isn't
interested in your conflict so you get
foreign ministers you get presidents you
get people visiting from all over the
world
doesn't interest them so if the conflict
doesn't interest them why are you so
exercised over something like boycott
divestment and sanctions why does the
anti-defamation league point out that
the number of BDS campaigns is doubled
in America of the last academic year
why are you allocating special funds
hundred million shekels to fight boycott
divestment sanctions if you're not
worried about it actually Israel's
economy has never been better
we had the two and a half billion
dollars of VC investment in start-up
companies two years ago 3.6 billion last
year four and a half billion this year
you know the the a BDS hold on the GPS
that you use to get to work has Israeli
technology idea this dent in your heart
is Israeli technology the water
technology that grew this plant is
Israeli technology Intel chips are made
in Israel the EU knows now the ravening
proposals that reach into your banking
your loans and mortgages your
qualifications for settlement
institutions as well as the tax-exempt
status of European charities that deal
with your settlements so they're going
to be attacking your financial
institutions well the reality is that
we've never really worried about that
we're always concerned about everything
but and especially when there's
countries who exercise very soon I was
concerned about me are concerned but you
know I come from the high tech industry
I ran a high-tech company that today
secures 70% of North American
transactions and UK transactions
Citibank Chase Bank of America are all
protected hundreds of millions of
customers are protected by technology
that my personal engineers and my
company developed I don't think the one
word and banks don't want to trade you
any money I will do business oh you're
being because that's the threat your
president is through which they're
looking at Israel if someone wants to
give up on the best technology in the
world only second you know in terms of
size we're only second to Silicon Valley
Israel has the best high tech industry
per capita I keep saying divine but what
about the other two
what about the attitude of the rest of
the world you're either worried about it
which your Foreign Ministry's constantly
says it is or you say everything's fine
them the rest of the world isn't
concerned about
I'll confess to the work is very
concerned about you if there is one
unique place I'll tell you no China
India are our Commerce is growing
exponentially United States Western
Europe the EU there are pockets of
anti-semitism that whatever we do they
don't care that the Bizon anti-semitism
is they just criticism well why couldn't
you just accept its Krita see you know
why I'll tell you why because when you
apply a double standard in Israel a
standard that you don't apply yourself
but you do a plan in Israel when you see
that asset is butchering quarter of a
million of its own people and what you
really care about is building another
kindergarten or not in a settlement I
call that double standard when you see
the only democracy in the Middle East
fight for its life and defend itself and
then you talk about excessive force
that's a double standard I call that
anti-semitism it's been around for about
2,000 years and it's stemmed from Europe
but I want to say most of Europe is not
anti-semitic but there are pockets of it
and unfortunately especially with the
growing Islamic presence in Europe it is
growing this is a problem you know move
around well Islam is anti so more than
130 countries have recognized at the UN
have recognized Palestine as a state and
you want the Palestinians to give up
forever on this idea of a Palestinian
state
you're too late aren't you I'm not you
know way too late then let me tell you
something I have four children ten year
old eight year old six and three will
have just ten minutes from the proposed
Palestinian state if we were to form a
Palestinian state according to these 130
countries and place a radical Islamic
state just 10 minutes from my house I
would put my children a harm's way
doesn't have to be Araku Islam not going
to happen as it
what does not have to be in la-la land
it's not in reality it is because we're
not living in a soap opera Tim we live
in Israel we live in the heart of the
toughest place in the world and and yet
we still have a vibrant democracy I'm
proud of it but what your president says
despite all spite the criticism ital our
imperfections though I'm sure the
rest of the world is perfect I want to
see what what the Londoners and what
Berliners would do if thousands of
radical Islamic terrorists would be
running around trying to kill them let's
see what what did the Ferguson Missouri
do was that excessive force what what
did in Baltimore you know every police
force in the world would do exactly what
we're doing probably much more in terms
of defending its people that's all we're
doing we're defending ourselves enough
Tony Bennett thanks for being on
conflict zone thank you very much this
was great thank you
you